tons of people asked like what's my diet
like during pregnancy because I normally
only eat meat and like I said I'm still
only eating meat would I recommend it
for pregnancy I would recommend you do
the diet that makes you feel the best
during pregnancy so unfortunately for me
that is still the lion diet I can't
incorporate other Foods if I could eat
anything else without getting autoimmune
flareups and by an autoimmune flare up I
mean arthritis my skin breaks out which
I hate badly uh and I go crazy I get
super volatile I can't think I get brain
foggy I get anxious I just want to hide
in bed if that didn't happen when I ate
other Foods I would 100% be eating other
Foods in general but especially during
pregnancy the number of times I've cried
over not being able to eat a cucumber
during this pregnancy is at least I
would say that happened at least 15
times uh because of the meat
aversion during the first
trimester all I wanted was like
cucumbers and it you know people should
be able to eat cucumbers without getting
autoimmune symptoms which I still think
is because I was living in mold for most
of my life but time will tell for that
but I would say do the diet that makes
you feel the best don't just give into
your random cravings for bad foods
because that does impact your health and
it does impact the health of your baby
so you shouldn't just be loading up on
carbs and gaining excess weight and not
caring about your body um but by no
means do I think that you should be only
eating beef like me it doesn't even feel
like that's what I should be
doing uh right
like the fact that I wanted a cucumber
so badly it's just like it's just some
vegetables like it's not that big a deal
but alas I can't do that yet so anyway
yes I've done carnivore throughout the
pregnancy it has been difficult I don't
know very many pregnant women that
actually stuck to a very strict
carnivore diet throughout pregnancy most
people add in at least a variety of
meats um and dairy
eggs and then a lot of people are like
well I couldn't even do that cuz I had a
meav verion I went back to like a paleo
diet I think that makes sense but I
couldn't do it which has made this
difficult any food or supplement you
recommend for pregnancy I think on any
restricted diet and and any diet it's
the standard American diet for sure you
should be monitoring your vitamins I've
I know now that your vitamin levels
aren't just from what you eat they're
also from your environment my vitamin
levels were totally fine for like 5
years and then I moved into this
particularly moldy house that made me
really sick
and a whole bunch of them plummeted this
was right before I got pregnant so
fortunately I had started supplementing
the really deficient vitamins prior to
pregnancy so full for example I was
taking by injection I'll link the
injection below if you guys want to
inject full light I couldn't take the or
oral version because it gave me insomnia
for who knows like why for whatever is
wrong with my body so I injected it got
my levels back up to normal and then
that was about 8 weeks after we moved
out of mold and that's when I got
pregnant so I would suggest monitoring
your vitamins and supplementing
whatever's
low and looking at folate specifically
because at the very beginning FID is
important for the uh baby are you eating
organ meat now for the baby hell no okay
this dies hard enough with a meat
aversion I don't like organs the
idea the idea of liver
is so
nauseating no I'm not eating organs I
still don't really believe the whole
organ thing I think if you're on a
regular diet and you incorporate organs
in you can get some benefits but I think
if you're only eating meat I don't I
don't I haven't seen any definitive
evidence of adding in organs and getting
some sort of benefit so I'm not doing it
I also think it's weird to desiccate
something that you don't even want to
swallow and then force yourself to take
it by pill if your body is like trying
to make you spit it out so that's still
my opinion no I'm not eating organs
having any issues with blood sugars
during pregnancy on Carnivore so they
get you so when you have a midwife they
pretty much follow what an OBGYN would
do although they explain like what
certain blood tests are for and they let
you opt into things but I did keep an
eye on my blood sugar for like a week
just to see it is very difficult to get
gestational diabetes if you only eat
meat if you're not having any carbs not
that any mainstream doctor would admit
to that but how do you get high blood
sugar when you'll need meat so no my
blood sugar has been about 83 to 87 for
the entire
pregnancy uh and I have been in ketosis
the whole time do doctors get mad at you
your diet while pregnant some would but
like screw those guys the the world is
is made up
of people who say they know what they're
talking about and don't most people so
if you get a doctor that's like well you
can't do that for all these
reasons do what makes your body the
healthiest be smart like monitor your
vitamins make sure you're not getting a
deficiency of some sort oh if a doctor's
getting mad at you too get a new doctor
I haven't even talked to a doctor have I
talked to a doctor throughout this whole
pregnancy
no for the first ultrasound I was in
Dubai and so then a doctor was like an
ultrasound technician did the ultrasound
and then the doctor was like yes that's
a baby that's the only doctor I've
talked to and it's going to stay that
way assuming everything goes well do you
ever worry about your child's nutrition
in the womb while being a meat eater no
I mean I've had like when I was when I
had Scarlet I was
eating salad and meat and I had so many
people freaking out about me only eating
salad and meat freaking out it was
really stressful
um my family wasn't freaking out but
everybody other than my parents were was
freaking out even though I was just
trying to keep my arthritis under
control was like those foods give me
arthritis that can't be good for the
baby so do I worry about the child's
nutrition no because babies will take
what they need from you so so if you're
so deficient in a vitamin that the baby
can't even take that vitamin from you
that's when you get a problem so keep an
eye on your vitamins my vitamins are
good I have been supplementing fall
light just in case um so no I'm not
worried about that at all I think that
it's I think the diet I'm on is
healthier than what most people eat so
even though I'd like to expand it and I
think it would be better I I don't even
know where I stand with that exactly I
would really like a cucumber so
I feel like I should have be able to eat
a cucumber if I really want one but um
my body doesn't like it yet so we're
going to wait on
that I am still using electrolytes I
don't use them very often but I take
electrolytes sometimes but I'm really
just eating beef so like right now cuz
the meav verion is still here and
unpleasant I'm eating a lot of TR tip
for some reason TR tip isn't as
nauseating as like aged steak like lamb
is completely off the table lamb is oh I
don't know what I'd rather eat liver or
lamb but they're both pretty low on the
list so Lamb's gone that was way too
hard uh fish tasted bad didn't make me
feel very good even chicken kind of
tasted like fish everything's just
tasting like fish in a bad way or
blueberries like I've gone out for steak
and I've been like why does the steak
taste like blueberries and Jordan's like
what are you talking about like G meat
aversion this is so I'm eating TR tip
and like here's my sexy bag of
jerky I love jerky but I don't really
love jerky pregnant but I'm eating it I
still need to
eat so diet's the
same I took full light as like a
prenatal and throughout pregnancy by
injection and yes I still include
electrolytes I haven't changed other
than that although I did try to because
the Met aversion was so bad and it
didn't go
well
[Music]
a